zeke
zeke and mary are going to the prom
together
well you know um
okay
uh just one item for all of you at the
top
on monday the president will join the
business roundtable ceo quarterly
meeting at their headquarters in
washington d.c to discuss the united
states response to russia's unprovoked
and unjustified war with ukraine and the
president's plans to lower costs for
working families create good paying
union jobs and tackle the climate crisis
on wednesday as you all know he will
travel to brussels belgium where he will
have a packed thursday he will he's
traveling that day there's not a
schedule that day uh but eat your
wheaties eat your spinach it's gonna be
a long thursday
because on thursday to start the day the
president will attend an extraordinary
nato summit to discuss ongoing
deterrence and defense efforts in
response to russia's unprovoked and
unjustified attack on ukraine he will
also reaffirm our ironclad commitment to
our nato allies and to defend every inch
of our nato territo of nato territory
then he will join a scheduled european
council summit to discuss our shared
concerns about ukraine including
transatlantic efforts to impose economic
sanctions on russia provide humanitarian
support to those affected by the
violence and address other challenges
related to the conflict later in the day
he will attend the g7 meeting called by
germany to further discuss with our
allies and partners the consequences we
are imposing on russia for its war of
choice uh we'll have more announcements
i'm certain on the trip uh in the days
ahead i don't have additional details
we've also of course invited our
national security advisor
who always enjoys engaging with all of
you uh to join us to preview the trip
early next week so we're just figuring
out the date and the time depending on
when the charter leaves with that sequin
should kick us off no updates on the
friday schedule don't have any updates
at this point in time um on to the
president's call this morning with
president
does the white house now have a sense of
whether or not china
has decided whether to assist russia
backfill its supplies and fulfill its
request for
material this one's
agreement
well i'm not going to give an assessment
of that from here what i can tell you is
that the majority of this call as i
think you heard it you saw in the
readout and you heard i think on the
call we just did
but was focused on uh russia's
unprovoked invasion of ukraine the
president spent the vast majority of the
nearly two hours was spent with the
president outlining the views of the
united states and our allies and
partners on this crisis including a
detailed overview of efforts to prevent
and then respond to the invasion how we
got here steps we've taken where where
we've gone and why
and of course as was also noted in the
readout but let me just reiterate uh he
also uh conveyed and described the
implications and consequences of china
provides material support to russia but
again i'm not going to provide any
additional assessment from here the
president has cast
the
efforts to build up the the western
alliance and sort of the democracies
versus autonomy
one
very like the largest democracy of the
world is in fact buying russian oil
right now at a discount uh expanding its
purpose and taking advantage of the
situation does the white house have any
response to india's purchases there and
uh
instead of the president plan to reach
out
to the indian government to try to get
that decision reversed well we have not
uh well we made a decision about banning
the russian import of oil every country
has not made that decision and we
recognize that and they have different
economic reasoning as to why different
countries do including some in europe we
have been in touch of course with uh
indian leaders at a range of levels not
through the president uh if that happens
we will of course provide that readout
and information to all of you but what
we would project or convey to any leader
around the world is that the
world the rest of the world is watching
uh where you're going to stand as it
relates to this conflict uh whether it's
support for russia
in any form as they are illegally
invading ukraine
we saw this week pfizer request to the
ua for uh yeah a fourth up fourth with a
fourth shot of the second booster votes
seniors and madonna last night was just
for all adults and other issues does the
federal government have the money right
now to purchase the doses needed to
give everyone the boosters should that
should be fda and cdc clear that well
just to reiterate some of the pieces of
where the process is um so the cdc
does recommend fourth doses for the
immunocompromised uh well it hasn't been
of course as you noted approved for
others and they're running a vigorous
data-driven process and right now over
100 million americans uh have been
boosted millions more have not done so
and are eligible to do so and need to
get boosted but to go to your question
we've been clear we need additional
funding from congress you've heard me
talk about that a fair amount in here
including for the possibility of a
fourth dose or a variant specific
vaccine so we would indeed need
additional funding to ensure that can be
widely available
but
during the readout of this call a senior
official said that the president was
really sort of laying out his assessment
of the situation to president xi that he
was making clear the implications of
certain actions but that president biden
wasn't making specific requests of china
why not and given the stakes here
because china has to make a decision for
themselves about where they want to
stand uh and how they want the history
books to uh look at them and view their
actions and that is the decision for
president xi and the chinese to make
given the growing concerns about
china possibly aligning with russia
would you say it's more concerning at
this point that they would help russia
resupply help russia with military
equipment or that they would offer
economic support to help russia evade
sanctions uh any of those would be
concerning to us but i'm not going to
give a rank order assessment of which
we're more concerned about and you don't
have a sense that china may be leaning
more in one direction or another not an
assessment i can provide from here
sort of a logistical question you know
the chinese got out a readout of the
call fairly quickly before it was even
done
it was i think three and a half is
remarkable
before your readout should we read
anything into the the time that it took
to to get your side of the story out so
it was a lengthy call as you all know
two hour call is of course a lengthy
call even with translation and what
typically happens and this time is a
little longer than typical but is uh
there's a you know meeting to discuss
what happened during the meeting and
assess what kind of information we can
provide publicly obviously we want to do
as much as that as possible to all of
you but we also want to ensure we're
protecting the diplomatic channels and
conversations so it was an effort to do
exactly that go ahead yeah i just wanted
to ask so you know we've spoken to u.s
and european diplomats who say that
there's still not exactly
an agreement on what the red line would
be that you know what when china would
face consequences can you say a little
bit more about
those discussions and whether there is
agreement with the
g7 allies and others who joined in about
what the trigger is and and what sort of
consequences
well andre i would say you know the um
the um
the movement of
china to align with russia or to um
yeah the movement of them to align with
russia or their their proximity of
moving closer together is certainly of
great concern to us as we've expressed
and we are not the only country that has
expressed that concern including many
other members of the g7 have expressed
exactly that concern so this is part of
the discussion has been an ongoing part
of the discussion expect it certainly
would be when the president goes to
europe uh next week but we're not in a
place at this point to outline the
specifics we're still discussing
um and then just to follow up on that
the um
initially i think going into the call we
were expecting that there would be
discussion about iran and north korea as
well did the two leaders get around to
those issues and are there any closer in
terms of alignment on those issues
and then just to your first point um or
your response
one of the issues that has separated the
us and china over in recent years has
been
disputes over trade and lots of tariffs
and would you anticipate that china
would face a larger trade war
if uh or or additional sanctions and
tariffs if uh if it does proceed to
align closer and more closely well we
have a range of tools that could be
considered um and sanctions are
certainly one tool in the toolbox um as
they are for other countries as well
even if we as we have not uh outlined
specific consequences and we'll we'll
communicate those directly to china and
of course with our european partners and
counterparts uh the the call was was
focused as the readout conveyed uh the
vast majority of it was uh on uh
russia's unprovoked invasion of ukraine
uh but also the issue of taiwan was
raised by the chinese
and the president reiterated that u.s
policy on taiwan has not changed that
was really the vast majority of the
focus of the call obviously there are a
range of issues and topics we discussed
with the chinese
and as a part of this call there was an
agreement on uh ensuring there was an
open line of communication and that the
discussion would continue um in this
critical period ahead of course at lower
levels go ahead during the show recall
did president xi ever refer to it as an
invasion
we'll let president xi and his team
outline any more specifics about his uh
component of the conversation why not
reveal if he called it an invasion or
called an award because we don't as a
policy uh speak for other countries they
can speak for themselves
yesterday secretary of lincoln said the
administration was concerned that china
is considering answering russia's
request for more military equipment
after this jail were called does the
white house still have that concern we
have that concern the president detailed
um uh you know what the implications and
consequences would be if china provides
material support to russia um as it
conducts brutal attacks against
ukrainian cities and civilians and
obviously that is something we will be
watching and the world will be watching
concern hasn't gone away following the
call obviously actions are a key part of
what we'll be watching and russian
foreign minister lavrov says that russia
will view any weapons shipments into
ukraine as quote legitimate targets
obviously president biden just
authorized 800 million dollars in more
security assistance aka weapons
potentially going into ukraine so what
is the president's response to that
comment well that's a threat that he has
uh made before i would just note um
foreign minister lavrov i would note
that just in terms of how it works
without getting into too many logistics
of course there are no u.s troops
operating inside ukraine our forces are
in nato territory and so are nato forces
in nato territory um so as we're talking
about the operations of the movement of
convoys and the movement of of
assistance um that is those are not the
bodies that would be moving those
assistants within ukraine um
so beyond that though i would say of
course we uh we watch closely what the
actions are the continued escalatory
actions of of the russians um and uh and
we will watch closely if they follow up
on that threat i would remind you all
that all of the convoys are not just
moving military assistance many of them
are moving humanitarian assistance as
well food
you know and other aid that is getting
to people who have been injured through
this brutal invasion i guess the
question is how concerned are you about
being able to get all 800 million
dollars of that assistance that's
obviously so critically needed into
ukraine well we continue to have the
means of getting that assistance in uh
and we have effectively been doing that
uh in recent days and so we will
continue to work through those channels
thank you go ahead thank you jen
depressment biden directly ask president
xi if he intends to help russia
well he made clear uh what the
implications and the consequences would
be if china provides material support to
russia as it conducts brutal attacks
against ukrainian cities and civilians
and that made clear what the
consequences would be should they do
that did he ask
do you intend to help russia yes or no i
think making clear what the consequences
are make clear we don't want them to do
it so can you offer any explanation for
why the u.s still has concerns after
this call because we'll continue to
watch until
we see what actions they take or don't
take and following up on andrea's
question does the administration view
any distinction between
financial support and military support
for russia or well the consequences um
will there be consequences regardless of
what kind we would watch closely and
there we would be prepared for there to
be consequences but we would look
closely on what it is and we would align
with our partners around the world
consequences like we've seen with russia
again i'm not going to get into a
hypothetical at this point in time we'll
have those discussions directly with the
chinese and directly with our european
partners and one more um short of
getting any guarantees from china that
they are not going to help russia and
short of china condemning russia for its
actions
what is it about the call that president
biden thinks went well as he said to one
of my colleagues i think it was an
opportunity for the president to convey
directly what our detailed efforts have
been
what we have seen on the ground how we
have responded to the invasion
why we have the significant level of
concern that we have and also to convey
very directly leader to leader uh what
the implications and consequences would
be if russia provides material support
and that leader to leader engagement and
opportunity for there to be a continuing
discussion uh certainly the president
sees as a positive uh as a positive uh
development go ahead thank you jen
a couple of days ago you described
javelins and stingers as defensive
weapons and migs and planes as offensive
weapons so how do we classify the armed
drones that we're sending
any i would remind everybody that russia
is invading ukraine not the other way
around ukraine is not invading russia
they are not going into a foreign
country and invading that country and
what we're sending to ukraine is
security assistance all of it and
weapons that they are effectively using
to defend their country against russian
aggression and that is how all of this
material would be categorized in that
sense then wouldn't migs also be
defensive since ukraine is defending
itself from attacks
from russia well again this is all
assessments made by our defense
department but i would tell you that
as it relates to the transfer of fighter
planes from a u.s base in germany into
contested ukrainian airspace where our
military and intelligence committee
determined the benefits provided to
ukraine's defense are low and the risks
of escalation are high that is how we
assess that but also those type of of
planes would be a different category of
military assistance it seems like we're
splitting hairs over semantics
in terms of how we're classifying some
of these weapon systems and obviously
the president's gotten some criticism
from
both sides of the aisle for even when he
takes action
sometimes doing it after there's been a
lot of political pressure uh for
instance on
imposing the sanctions on sending the
stingers and the javelins on banning
russian oil so if there's any chance
that the u.s is going to facilitate the
transfer of migs in some way why not
just do it now
well i think we've outlined pretty
clearly why we've made the decision not
to do that including the fact that they
have multiple squadrons of planes that
they can utilize and the fact that most
importantly the types of assistance that
we've been providing
anti-armor anti-tank anti-missiles is
what is effective in fighting this war
on the ground that is why we've provided
that assistance none of the weapons
we've sent to ukraine could be used to
launch an invasion of another of a
country like russia that's a fact that's
why we call them defensive weapons
that's why the defense department calls
them defensive weapons and i would
remind everybody that they are the
country that are under attack i want a
bunch of the iranian talks um this week
the president said that
we are crippling putin's economy with
punishing sanctions that are only going
to grow more painful over time
but the state department said that the
administration would not sanction
russian participation in nuclear
projects that are part of the
jcpoa so
how does the administration justify
calling for such strong sanctions on
russia but giving them a pass when it
comes to iran isn't that
hypocritical in some sense there's
absolutely no past given they're not
getting additional assistance or
sanctions relief of any sort they have
an implementation role they've had an
implementation role in the past
as it relates to the iran nuclear deal
and that
is certainly what we would be talking
about in this regard but for clarity
purposes there's absolutely no uh no
additional sanctions assistance that
russia would be receiving that is
outside of the iran nuclear deal
but just carving out what's already
there and giving it protection that it
will not
be sanctioned well to explain to you or
for those of you who have covered back
in 2015 you may remember this that there
was there have been roles in the past
that russia has played in terms of the
the movement or the protection the
nuclear protections in some capacity of
as we're implementing the iran deal um
and that's what we're really referring
to that's part of the discussion in the
deal
that we're doing
it's the similar implementation
components it's a implementation and
discussion around a similar deal that
was discussed back in 2015. the director
of national intelligence annual threat
assessment last month said that iran
has threatened to kill former and
current u.s officials in retaliation for
the u.s killing the irgc's leader hasan
solomoni
so do those threats constitute terrorism
well i would just remind you all that um
where we are one i'm not going to
just confirm or get into specifics about
any threats through intelligence
channels but where we are right now
well where we are right now is that uh
not only has iran's nuclear uh program
advanced but their behavior in the
region and beyond has gotten more
aggressive including by the islamic
revolutionary guard so the notion that
the actions of the past administration
pulling out of the iran nuclear deal has
uh has cut down on the actions or the
escalatory behavior of the iranian
revolutionary uh guard is inaccurate
they've actually the iranian government
has actually doubled uh their budget or
something like that so the notion that
the approach that the status quo is
effective and making us safer just
doesn't bear out in any form of facts
so they should not then um the irg cbd
listed from the
terrorist black lives there's an ongoing
negotiation i'm not going to get into
specifics of it but i would just note
that the
status quo where we stand has done
nothing to make us safer in any regard
in fact the islamic revolutionary guard
has only been strengthened go ahead i
want to follow up with you on the call
you have from the podium and in the
readout it says the president described
the implications and consequences if
china provides material support to
russia so to be clear did president
biden warn president xi not to send any
support to russia i think he made clear
what the implications and consequences
would be if he did that is laying out
what the consequences would be president
she has to decide what he's going to do
here
is it fair to characterize that as a
warning i would characterize it exactly
as i said it and did president biden and
president xi discuss
the possibility of lifting sanctions and
or tariffs as a way to get china this
was not about carrots this was about
laying out what the implications and
consequences would
be step away from the phone call and
have a sense that he can work with china
as it relates to you
well i think he came away uh feeling
that he had conveyed clearly what the
implications and consequences would be
and also that he had the opportunity to
lay out specifically what steps we've
taken why and what we're seeing on the
ground and he also said that we would
continue conversations uh at um
test the teams to continue conversations
so that indicates that we will continue
to engage with them i want to follow up
with you on something we've been
discussing throughout the week the issue
of refugees newsweek has reported that
the u.s is actually detaining ukrainian
refugees and ice detention centers
those who are seeking entry into the
country which seems like a contradiction
of president biden saying that he would
welcome them here can you tell us why
this is happening and what's being done
i can't confirm any specific cases i'd
point to the department of homeland
security but what i would say is that
we are still implementing our
immigration laws at the border that
means that title 42 is in place and for
individuals who uh come through uh you
know abnormal migration we
approach that through the same laws and
implementation when the president says
he would welcome refugees of course he
would but they have to apply through the
refugee programs
do you acknowledge them that detaining
them is a contradiction to president
biden saying he would welcome them
well again kristen we implement and we
are immigration laws across the board no
matter what country you come from um and
that has been our case and approach from
the beginning welcoming refugees means
applying through the refugee process and
again as i've said in here we're looking
at a range of options including
providing a broad range of humanitarian
assistance to the countries where the
vast majority of refugees are going is
it a priority for president to address
this situation so that refugees are not
being detained
well again we are continuing to apply
our immigration laws at the border and
so refugees who want to come to the
united states of course we would welcome
ukrainian refugees that is why but they
have to apply through the existing
programs there's an ongoing discussion
about what programs or what steps we
could take and we certainly that's an
important conversation and process
internally where we have put all of our
efforts to date the vast majority of
them to date has been on providing a
historic amount of funding to
countries in the region including a huge
amount billions of dollars that has been
approved through the omnibus bill the
president just signed into law to make
sure that the countries that are
welcoming the vast majority of these
refugees have assistance and support and
aid that they need jen you mentioned
taiwan will the u.s deliver javelins and
stingers on time this year to taiwan can
you answer that uh i don't have any
update for you on military assistance to
taiwan i would appoint you the
department of defense
real quick the white house is it aware
of ongoing destruction
and vandalism of catholic churches
across the united states statues as well
is the president aware of that
destruction taking place right now
across the u.s most recent examples in
florida at the holy family catholic
church
in royal oak michigan saint mary
catholic church
in georgia sacred heart catholic church
all vandalized destroyed
i can assure you that the president the
white house in the united states would
oppose any destruction or desecration of
religious institutions of any kind and
certainly catholic churches the
president himself is a catholic of
course does
the president believe that perhaps pope
francis could play a role in mediating
an end to this ukrainian crisis the war
i just don't have anything on pope
francis's role obviously we're focusing
our efforts at this point in time and
engaging with our european allies and
counterparts around the world go ahead
ashley uh if president biden does not
make a second stop on his trip abroad
next week as has been rumored to poland
or some other place what would be the
reason would it be security concerns
would it not be wanting to visit
refugees at the border to draw resources
away from that crisis
i expect we'll have more on the trip
soon so i don't want to get too ahead of
where we may or may not be but we factor
in a range of factors whenever we make
any travel plans um including pulling
resources away as you noted um including
security concerns including uh you know
ensuring that we can implement it
effectively but uh we pulled this trip
together pretty quickly so we're working
as quickly as we can to get any other
details finalized a different topic
following up on what my colleague asked
yesterday president zielinski mentioned
in his address this idea of a u-24 um
united for peace what it's a little
unclear to me at least what exactly that
would look like i mean what is the white
house's understanding of what he's
asking for is that an alternative to
nato what role would it feel can you we
just don't have any other assessment or
explanation from here i mean i'd
certainly point you to the ukrainians to
discuss in more detail we we talk with
them regularly
i don't i would let them speak for their
own proposals go ahead
jim did when the president spoke to
president g did he set out any um
particular benchmarks by which
it would measure
their compliance either financially on
the arms issue any time frames out there
but
did he lay did he come to some kind of
understanding or declaration of the
presidency about how he would be
measuring success
success in terms of whether or not he
provides material support
i don't have anything more to outline on
that for you i would just say that the
call was not about making asks it wasn't
about making assessments it was about uh
having an ongoing discussion and
dialogue about the illegal invasion or
the invasion of
of russia's unprovoked invasion of
ukraine there any discussion of the
agreement that president xi
reached with president putin
just at the opening of the elections
i just don't have more details on the
call to read out beyond what we've
conveyed to go ahead what can you say
about the severity of the implications
and consequences for russia for china if
they do indeed uh
in the estimation of the u.s provide
material support to russia i mean are
these to the level which should really
make china think twice before assisting
russia
it's up to president xi and the chinese
to make that decision but the president
again uh laid out very clearly and
directly uh in the call what the
implications and consequences would be
if they provided material support why is
the white house choosing not to
elaborate and disclose more about what
the the consequences could be because we
feel that it would be most constructive
to have those conversations directly
with the chinese
good
hi um a senior administration official
just told us that the president that
president didn't make any specific
requests to she and that china will make
its own decisions but i think i just
said that too
there you go but we're nearing a pretty
critical point in the war where
according to your own assessment russia
seems poised to potentially deploy bio
or chemical weapons how much time is
there for china to really
weigh in here with putin and why not
press for that while on the call
i think that the primary focus of this
call was for the president to lay out
specifically the consequences and
specifically where we've come to date um
his assessment was that that was the
most constructive
way to spend the call and it's going to
be up to president xi and the chinese to
determine what role they're going to
play moving forward go ahead
implications of consequences yeah i'm
asking about this again because in the
lead up to russians invasion uh the
white house was really extremely
transparent laying out call after call
and briefing after briefing a lot of the
specific that we then saw implemented
why in this case is it just saying
implications and consequences and not
giving the same specifics sure because
we feel it's the most constructive way
to engage and have a constructive
dialogue
just to clarify
the specifics were given out in detail
on this call it sounds weird every every
uh well i again i'm not going to give
you more details about the level of
detail but it was a detailed engagement
i'm not going to outline that more from
here but it was
he was uh again he was specific about
what he described on the call go ahead
um i hope i'm not beating a dead horse
here it's okay yeah okay it's friday
um so you you surprisingly the point of
this call be to see where she stands yep
um europe's reluctant to tell us where
she stands places i call um and he
promises the chinese but their readout
if you've read it is uh yeah doesn't
tell you much either
um so can you at least say after a two
hour call
is a white house confident it knows
where she stands and you just don't want
to tell us or are you not telling us
because you don't really understand
where he stands i think uh what i can
tell you is that they test the teams
with having continued discussions but
i'm not going to provide you any
additional assessment from here go in
the middle and how does president biden
define the current chinese and u.s
relationship right now and have you
scheduled more communications meetings
calls
yeah they test the teams to follow up on
today's conversation and on in this
critical period ahead i don't have
anything in terms of when that will take
place but that was part of it go ahead
following the recent texas primary
election the ap is reporting that
roughly 13 of ballots uh were discarded
following you know new statewide
election laws one is the white house
concerned about these new numbers and
has the white house uh put in a new plan
to try and get some sort of federal
voting rights legislation or uh
executive order and act and to
implementation well certainly we will
continue to stay we remain committed the
president the vice president remain
committed to doing everything we can to
get voting rights legislation passed and
move forward and these reports are
certainly a reminder of how important
that is in terms of the specifics of it
i'd really point you to the democratic
party committee uh on the political side
of this and i will see if our team has
any other specific reaction from here
another question um we know next week
the supreme court uh nominee just our
judge yeah kentucky brown jackson will
be going for it with hearings uh there
are some new accusations from capitol
hill um some republicans still saying
that she soft on crime senator josh
holly person saying that she saw
particularly on sex offenders um what is
the white house's response to these new
accusations and are you at all concerned
that it might take public view as we go
to parents next week i think as we
broadly look at it i mean after weeks of
trying hard to find some way to attack
judge jackson for saying that she was an
affirmative action pick than saying she
was the product of dark money then
saying she should be us
she should be suspect because she was a
public defender a group of far-right
republican senators as you noted have
launched a last-ditched eve of hearing
desperation attack on her record on
sentencing in sexual offense cases what
is important here i think are the facts
and the facts are that in the vast
majority of cases involving child sex
crimes broadly the sentences judge
jackson imposed were consistent with or
above what the government or u.s
probation recommended and so this attack
that we've seen over the last couple of
days relies on factual inaccuracies and
taking judge jackson's record widely out
of context
it dishonestly took a snippet of a
transcript out of context when in fact
judge jackson was repeating something a
witness said in order to ask a question
about their testimony it also admits
that omits that the sentencing
commission report mentioned was
unanimously approved by the commission
and is by law which is by law bipartisan
with equal representation so we're going
to continue from here to reiterate what
the actual facts are uh and we hope that
uh those who are taking this process
seriously or state that they are taking
this process seriously we'll also look
to the facts and not disingenuous
attacks go ahead two questions about
covet you talked earlier to zeke's
question about the additional funding
being needed to ensure that the fourth
dose boosters yeah widely available
secretary becerra said today that
hopefully soon the government will be
telling parents of kids under five that
they can get their kids vaccinated and
he said that will also put strain on the
system is there any chance that the
vaccine doses for the kids under five
wouldn't be available if this coveted
money doesn't come through it's not
about available i think it's about
making them free um so uh because
obviously these companies are going to
produce doses if it's one if and when at
some point as a as a mother of a child
under five god willing soon um making
them available what we want to be able
to do is continue to make them free um
so that is where our focus and our
concern is um and obviously beyond that
for people who are uninsured for people
who don't have the resources um to cover
the cost of a fourth dose or a vaccine
for their kid or otherwise this is
pretty important that we move this
funding forward so that we can continue
to provide these type of programs across
the country if there isn't additional
funding would this be the first age
group that would not get three shots
potentially like are you i'd have to
take that money to make sure that those
doses i'd have to check with our kova
team on it obviously they look since it
hasn't been approved yet what we've been
able to do is outline for you what
programs would have to be uh ended or
halted in the timeline of them but i can
check with them and see if there's any
specific planning for this but obviously
if we don't have funding it's hard to
make vaccines for anyone uh of free go
ahead
um reported earlier today that ron
secretly set up a banking and finance
system to get around the us-led
sanctions wondering if the u.s has a
response to that and if you think it
might complicate that
i'd have to check with our team on that
i don't have any confirmation of the
accuracy of that so let me check with
our team and see if we have concerns and
what our response would be earlier this
week you were asked whether dick
sullivan in his conversation with his
russian counterpart brought up the
hostages
he said you checked i was wondering if
you had any updates i did mean to get
back to you on that i apologize so let
me venture to do that this afternoon go
ahead uh
two questions first on the call there's
been in recent days
concerned voiced by u.s officials about
china amplifying russian disinformation
about the situation there did that come
up on the call what was said i just
don't have more details we've obviously
been very vocal about our concern on
that front but i don't have more details
about whether that was part of the
discussion and secondly an update on
earlier this week the second gentleman
tested positive for covid can you give
us update on the vice president has she
tested again since
she did and she tested negative again
today
you mentioned that on the call the
president focused on ukraine the chinese
side raised the issue of taiwan
obviously you're not giving us any
specifics on
sanctions um
export controls and such but was there a
discussion about broader trade relations
between the us and china and then i'll
have a follow-up question specific about
uh american investments in chinese tech
firms well the the vast the vast vast
majority of the call was about those two
topics um so beyond that i don't have
more to read out for you but that was
really the focus of the call okay and so
uh a couple of administration officials
have been advocating that the president
issues an executive order that ban that
would ban american investments in
chinese tech firms
what is the status of that what is
causing the delay does it have anything
to do with the tick tock oracle deal is
there an anticipated timeline i don't
have any update or preview of what that
looks like at this point in time go
ahead one thing on the on the global
pandemic response with the house of
representatives slashing the five
billion dollars that you've asked uh
from the omnibus omnibus bill does do
you have a plan b in trying to meet the
goal of delivering what the the rest of
the 700 million now out of the 1.2
billion voices that you have pledged
well i i can certainly check on how many
of those have already been purchased
which i think would be a helpful piece
of information but there is not a secret
fund that we have not told you about to
continue to provide the type of
free programs we have in the united
states or to provide the level of
international assistance that we would
like to continue to provide but let me
check and see of those doses we've
committed if there is a set number that
have already been purchased if there's
no more money then there'll be no no
more doses other than the ones that's
already been purchased because there
might not even be any money for the
delivery of those doses that have
already been we need we need additional
funding to continue to be uh the arsenal
of vaccines in the world thank you
thanks jen i wanted to go back to the
supreme court nomination
for next week can you talk uh in the
president's schedule you didn't mention
that and obviously he's not testifying
the nomination here not that we're
tracking but yeah
can you talk about how this white house
is preparing how judge jackson is
preparing for next week um how the
president will be involved and he's got
a lot going on next week as well
well i would say that judge jackson as
you know has a whole team of people
internally and externally who has been
helping her
through the preparation process
she won't surprise anyone start studying
and practicing and preparing as soon as
she was
nominated to
serve on the supreme court and that
process is obviously picked over for the
last couple of days and so our team will
be closely watching monitoring
the hearings next week i'm sure we'll be
responding to the inevitable doses of
misinformation that travel out as well i
also wanted to ask about covent testing
the administration announced that
families could order a second round yeah
rapid tests of eating a few weeks ago i
don't know what it was but recently yes
in the state of the union yeah thank you
um could you provide an update on how
many tests you've shipped at this point
and whether there's been
interest in that second round
i can certainly check and see if we have
an updated number i know there's been
interest but we'll see if there's an
updated number to provide brian go ahead
thank you jen i wanted to ask about the
rapport between she and president the
two men have shared a meal together
they've known each other for more than
10 years this is an important moment in
u.s chinese relations
how did their personal rapport play into
today's call well i would say um
they know each other and as you've noted
they've spent time together they've had
a range of direct and candid
conversations uh this is not the first
and that certainly contributes to the
president's ability to be as direct as
he is whether it is laying out how where
we've come from and why we are at this
point and his great concerns and
significant concerns about russia's
unprovoked invasion of ukraine and also
what the implications and consequences
would be so there's no question that the
president's time on the world stage his
uh prior relationship with president xi
having spent time with him engaged with
him directly had many multi-hour calls
and meetings with him um contributes to
his ability to have those type of
conversations president bring up those
past meetings in this two-hour call
today
i don't think there's a reason to bring
them up they both know that they've had
past meetings so
you know i think it just starts the
meeting from an understanding of where
the other is coming from go ahead in the
first event with the president today why
didn't the president choose to address
the phone call personally between he and
president xi
because it was about a different topic
and there's a lot of things the american
people care deeply about so it was uh
his effort to con communicate about our
own thing a range of issues when you
have the leader of the largest economy
in the world and the second largest
economy world they're talking they could
fall on either side of an invasion the
american people might want to hear
directly from the president we've
provided a range of updates briefings
readouts and hopefully you all will be
effective as i'm sure you will in
communicating that to the american
people on the call did the president
push china about business the chinese
companies doing business in russia well
i would say first that um you know the
president uh
as we all have made clear that there
have been implications as you see while
we have not asked companies to take
specific steps you look at russia and
what's happened there and what the
implications have been for the russian
economy of companies pulling out and i
know that's certainly something for
every country to watch as they're making
decisions about which side of this
conflict they're going to stand on go
ahead thanks jen poland is calling for
an international peacekeeping mission in
the ukraine is that something the us
would entertain or support and possibly
participate in i'd have to get more
details on what that looks like um i'm
happy to talk with our national security
team about that and then i have like a
fun friday question okay
the house passed the crown act which
bans discrimination based on hairstyle
is this something the administration
supports what they sign it into law if
the senate passed it i have seen that i
have not talked to our legislative team
about it i'm happy to do that and we'll
see if we can get you a fun front fun
friday answer back go ahead
um in response to the mistreatment of
african immigrants that were fleeing
ukraine the white house they put out a
statement um a couple of weeks ago
saying that they received assurances
from the u.n ukrainian authorities and
governments they're committed to the
fear and equal treatment of those
seeking departure but
dublin what are those assurances because
we're still hearing a lot of stories of
incidents that are happening with those
who are trying to play well i think it
is it is something we continue to watch
closely and we have seen reports of uh
that um you know that that we would be
we are concerned about um so we would
just raise those concerns we have
directly and we felt it was important to
put out a public statement at that time
to follow up on just a couple more
questions one houston can we expect the
president to sign the anti-lynching bill
i can check and see what the timing i
know we were waiting for the vice
president i think to get back from
travel but yeah and lastly about a
quarter of americans not vaccinated or
partially vaccinated numbers aren't
really budging um is there any move or
change to
the definition of what is fully
vaccinated that would be for the cdc to
determine there hasn't been a change at
this point in time it still remains
two doses but we are continuing to
encourage any american who has not
received a booster to do exactly that
because it would provide them additional
necessary protection go ahead on judge
jackson's hearings next week have some
of that prep work included conversations
between the nominee and the president
and any advice from the former chairman
of the judiciary committee i'm not going
to get into details about their private
conversations
so has he played so
he has not played a role in sort of the
prep or the he's not participating in
the mock preps no but uh he is certainly
excited about her uh hearings next week
and being confirmed to serve on the
bench
thanks jen um i've got a quick
clarification and two questions about
presidential conflicts of interest in
foreign affairs uh the first brief
clarification is the new york times
reported this week that the first sun
remains under criminal investigation
does the president still intend to stay
out of that case yes it's the department
of justice and i'm pointing to them and
my two questions about conflicts of
interest in foreign affairs first i have
a question about russia and then one
about china um on russia you told me
last year that you were unfamiliar with
the senate report that alleged that the
first son or a company linked to the
first son received 3.5 million dollars
from the richest woman in russia uh
subsequent reporting indicates that
president biden when he was vice
president had a dinner in georgetown
with the same woman in 2015.
this uh yelling about arena she has not
been sanctioned yet by the us government
how is president biden navigating
conflicts of interest when it comes to
uh sanctioning people who have done
business with his family and can you
explain to us what this 3.5 million
dollars was for i don't have any
confirmation of the accuracy of that
report so i have no more further details
about the conflicts of interest though
how he's navigating those when deciding
sanctions what would be his conflicts of
interest his son's company allegedly got
3.5 million
which i have no confirmation of and he's
continued to sanction oligarchs more
than we've ever sanctioned in the past
so i'm not sure that's a conflict of
interest
go ahead thank you go ahead i have a
question about russia i think we're
moving on because we've got to get some
more people go ahead
my question about the conflict of
interest when it comes to china is last
year the first son's attorney said that
he divested from a chinese investment
fund controlled by chinese state-owned
entities we have received not even basic
transparency about who bought out his
stake when this happened and how much
money changed hands did he actually
divest and if so can you agree to the
private citizen he doesn't work for the
government i'd point you to his
representatives thank you
i think we're done here thank you very
much go ahead and uh
did the president biden talk to
president xi jinping about the escalate
tensions on korean peninsula how did the
presidency response on this
again the vast vast majority of the call
was about
russia's unprovoked invasion of ukraine
and again when the chinese when
president xi raised taiwan the president
reiterated the u.s policy on taiwan
obviously there are a lot of important
issues that we discuss with the chinese
somewhere we work together somewhere we
have strong concern and there's a lot of
channels for that but that was the
primary focus of the conversation go
ahead this is john from white new city
pakistan pakistani prime minister imran
khan requested for a telephony
conversation with president pardon like
many many months ago it's like more than
40 or 15 months we haven't heard
anything about that is there any
specific reason for not communicating
with the pakistani leadership i don't
have any update on a planned call or
engagement obviously we engage with
pakistan and a range of leaders at a
number of levels through the state
department for our national security
team but in terms of a caller engagement
with the president i have anything to
predict on that front the recent visit
to russia pakistani prime minister imran
khan told the public gathering that he
will not be a slave of america like
other politicians too would you like to
comment on that i don't know why you say
that right we have a long uh
relationship with pakistan uh and that
is a relationship we'll continue through
diplomatic channels so i don't have any
more
uh comments on that go ahead thanks
thanks
oh we can go to both of you go ahead go
i don't know whoever wants to go first
you can rock people
you might have seen that uh
president putin held a rally
at which he said of the russian people
that we have not had unity like this for
a long time
is that your perception leave any
comment well we're not going to respond
uh to putin's president putin's
misinformation
uh and propaganda rally which is how we
see it
just a bigger picture question there's
been a lot of
discussion this week about war crimes
and war criminals and you're well aware
the united states does not recognize the
international criminal
does not remember yeah no remember
president biden believes that is the
correct stance and if so doesn't that
undercut
the united states uh moral authority
well i would note that there are a range
of international bodies that have
ongoing international investigations we
would not be the ones prosecuting of
course there'd be international bodies
uh prosecuting uh any case on war crimes
we're going to feed data and information
into that and they support uh their
process
okay well sebastian balkans please uh
russia and
china spreading the influence a lot on
western balkans especially bosnia
herzegovina and kosovo and the president
is a friend of bosnians and and kosovo's
can you assure people over there that
america is still with them
absolutely plea please send that
directly
go ahead yeah thank you very much and uh
as you know we celebrate our naruto's
new year afghan people has our
expectation do you have any message and
also yesterday president
yes yes yes um we did so the president
um did um sign tps for afghans um which
means that those who have been in the
country and let me get you the exact
information uh on that
um
let's see um
uh so um let's see um
uh okay
so basically okay so the tps will apply
only to those individuals who are
already residing in the united states as
of march 15 2022 and meet all other
requirements including under undergoing
security and background checks and this
is a designation decided by the
department of homeland security through
their process and their designated
afghanistan they designated afghanistan
for tps on the statutory basis of
ongoing armed conflict and extraordinary
and temporary conditions u.s citizens
and citizenship and immigration services
estimates that approximately 74 500
individuals in the united states would
become eligible for tps through the
designation
for afghanistan and that includes 72 500
who have been paroled into the united
states through operation allies welcome
and approximately 2 000 afghan nationals
who did not participate in the
operation allies welcome and were
otherwise in the united states already
so this is a new um designation just
announced this week
well i would say we um would send a
message of happy new year's to uh at the
afghan people and and certainly a
special shout out to afghan women and we
have huge admiration for their courage
their bravery and we will continue to
stand with them uh during these
challenging times thank you everyone
happy friday